so ein bisschen aber erst mal sagen mal
getroffen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge von wahr oder falsch
zusammen mit den gebrochenen daumen
projekt
also was ist etwas was ist das
eigentlich
diese muss ich jetzt machen
also das ist die firma für diese punkte
sind wir dann entscheidet ein
das ist eine lüge oder das der wahrheit
und die beiden spiele nicht in einem
team genau also kein team wir sind als
einzelne person pipapo auf jeden fall
und gehen wir davon aus ich hätte eine
story malte sagt dies falsch konkreter
sagt gies war und die war war dann
kriegt von craft einen punkt aber ich
sehe auch einen punkt an einer falsch
gelegen hatte genauso man kriegt immer
einen punkt wenn die leute falsch rat
hin
und ja wenn man richtig richtig richtig
dass gott uns jeder hat drei geschichten
und wir fangen einfach ganz links an
baldwins danach hätte ich deine story
und dann erzählt meine story kommt uns
übrigens auch stories die wir da
natürlich als falsch markieren per
e-mail schreiben und könnte das auch per
e mail oder web de bari wie ihr wollt
also privat mache ich bei denen am
besten nicht weil bei denen sind ja
beide daher am besten
wir blenden
ich möchte mein leben hier oben wandert
einfach aus story sind story 10 senden
am besten nicht eine kommentare könnt
ihr auch machen aber die werden wir dann
wahrscheinlich verwenden
das halten die können nur solche senden
und die sind dann als falsch
ja wir können ja man kann natürlich
lügen aber da sagen einfach dass wir da
und so wird er vertrauen das wir sagen
dass die story zwar sind die auch
wirklich wahr sind ja also ihr schon
ablehnen falls die nicht verstanden dass
sie war es so dass die falsch ist statt
der schleppe die story hin und pipapo
genau und dabei verbrennt wenn ihr
schaut am besten an e mail youtube namen
und wird auch erwähnt oder nicht doch
wenn wir die dann aufgelöst haben können
wir das ja genauso da kommt man jetzt
fangen wir müssen jetzt erstmal zum wolf
gewinner in seinen raum reingekommen wir
gehen jetzt in rom für geschichte immer
noch nicht da rein gucken ja dort kommt
man nicht schweizer waren da steht drin
die auflösung übrigens auch so
die erste folge kommt jetzt bei beiden
die zweite kommt dann bei mir die dritte
dann bei denen die väter bei mir und das
passiert immer montags okay okay bei mir
fängt es harmlos an
und umso weiter wieder in meinem gang
voranschreiten unsere heftiger heftiger
wird
der anfang ist wirklich harmlos
und zwar habe ich in meinem leben noch
nie eine zigarette in den mund genommen
eine walther zigarette gezogen oder an
einer shisha geraucht
ich habe überhaupt in meinem leben noch
nie geraucht
da also wirklich nicht einmal nicht
einmal so ok glauben sie nicht ich
glaube es falsch ok bei mir ist es so
ich kenne euch bei dir nicht beide kennt
euch also ein bisschen ich kenne ja
nicht ich kenne ich so ein bisschen aber
ich würde erstmal sagen ich kenne ich ja
noch nicht so lange
aber ich würde ganz grob sagen erst mal
das ist eine lüge war also whatsapp ihr
geht feiern hier blablabla so sachen die
halt so leute haben die auch wirklich
sozial integriert sind und wenn man
sozial integriert ist und ich glaube ich
solche leute die das motto haben man
lernt nicht das feuer heißt es ohne mal
anzufassen
hallo ich dass man alles mal
ausprobieren sollte und lüge dann kommt
man den kasten rein von der firma
als erstes die story ist einfach war das
nicht gedacht werde ich auch nicht
gedacht wahrscheinlich hätte der gedacht
dass das so offensichtlich ist dass wir
denken dass falsche chef dabei verwahrte
ich war ich weiß dass man also bei
drogen und so aber hätte jetzt also bei
uns kannst das doch zu ende vom ressort
leute da er so ein wenig ein wenig
abgeneigt ist
also bei mir ich hab es dort ja monster
vorher hieß es ja nicht erzählt er muss
darüber unterhalten
bei mir dachte ich einfach stories of
stories aus unserem leben aber so ist
das natürlich auch witzig wenn wir
solche sachen reinschreiben
bei mir ist die story imbiss ist anders
und zwar war ich im urlaub vor allem
jahr im sommer auch an der nordsee und
ich habe mir da am strand den arm
gebrochen beim volleyball
ja ich bin auf dem boden flog ich bin
richtig doof geflogen wirklich auf den
sand und das leipzig der am hals
gebrochen
jetzt hören weiter zu ya am war nicht
von anfang an gebrochen der war nur
angeknackst das nennt man ihn wie so
dass für handgelenk glaube ich und ich
dann natürlich es hat weh getan ich
hatte ein schockmoment und mir wohl
total kalt und schwitzig und blabla so
ein typischer schockmoment halt und dann
bin ich damit erst mal zum arzt gegangen
der insel arzt natürlich sinnvoll vogel
der kommende vollzog der dauerhaft als
andere tranken wäre jedenfalls er nimmt
mein arm sagt das ist gar nicht so
schlimm ich denke dass mal wieder ein
denkbar dass ein und dann war der arm
gebrochen und dann musste ich rüber
geflogen werden helikopter ins
krankenhaus weil da die schiffe nur alle
zwei tage fahren und so weiter und so
fort
und ja denkt ihr dass es war oder das
ist falsch das ist zu krass ausgedacht
als das ist also ich glaube es war ich
glaube auch dass es war weil das kann
niemals dass sie sich das ausgeguckte
rein
war das wirklich oder halt jetzt einfach
mal jedes buch richtig
dann habe ich mich über sich ich habe
eine story so ein bisschen aus meinem
leben gegriffen und zwar erreicht als
ich 16 war mit ein paar kollegen in
kroatien in der nähe von zagreb und ein
bisschen angetrunken weil man genau sein
typ erstmal warner 2 die nackt in den
brunnen getanzt haben und fotos von sich
gemacht haben und die zweispänner noch
mal getroffen hat der eine tief sind
einfach hundescheiße vom boden gegessen
und ich habe die ganze zeit gelacht
mein mund ist gerade genauso wie das
kind alter ich weiß nicht auf jedes mal
wenn ich denke eigentlich genau so hat
das ist so krass ausgedacht das ist das
muss war seien sogar dem motto weil du
denkst dass wir das falsch aber ich weiß
nicht ich hab noch nie menschen ich weiß
liebe ich will falsch sagen aber wenn
ich ihn falsch sagen da hat er auf jeden
fall ein punkt deswegen kaliber du hast
schon punkte ein
ja oh mein gott zurück wo er ankommen
würde wir schrecken das glaube ich oder
oder einfach gucken ich kann das nicht
okay war die acht- oder neunte klasse
aber ich noch so ein lieber junge
bisschen geschlendert hat mir so ein typ
dem brief überreicht was mit dem kaputt
alter nehme ich diesen brief dann hast
du schwul und die leute wissen
eigentlich wie homophobie schwindel
das spiel diesen brief und es war
einfach ein verschossener liebesbrief
vor diesem weg sein
die vermutung dass er schwul war weiß
ich nicht aber nach diesem brief war es
eindeutig dass er bis zu sexuell erregen
ich weiß es nicht ich denke mir gerade
kann wahr sein kann aber auch nicht zwar
seien die ersten story von ihm bayer war
deswegen glaube ich der denkt die denken
ich mache die falsch aber ich glaube
dies auch war das ist nicht okay also
ich sag war was ich sage auch war alles
kacke wenn man einiges falsch
nibelungen bei mir wieder gut
also leute meine zweite story wir waren
bei einem freund von mir auf dem kurs
treffen bisschen schön saufen garten
bisschen wasserpfeife bisschen dann so
angetrunken und wir laufen dann so wie
wir dann sind so um 2 oder so über
irgendwelche felder felder wir sie mit
dem fahrrad ins freibad gefahren wollten
einbrechen auf dem weg ist uns halt
sondern werde dann auf dem weg
aufgefallen
wir laufen dann über den zaun auf diese
kuhweide wo die kühe am schlafen waren
oder kühe umgeschubst waren war dann
nicht so eine gute idee weil die kühe
die können schon mal ganz schön harte
kräfte entwickeln da kommst du dann mit
deinem 44er bizeps die ich damals
natürlich schon hatte nicht so schnell
hinterher
ich habe aufgebaut ist es jetzt locker
schon 3000 meter ich bin oft gerade
dabei mir seinen vierten bildschirm zu
kaufen weil ich einfach die anderen
beiden nicht mehr sehe wegen selbst aber
das eine andere geschichte
jedenfalls wir schubsen diese kühe um
und alle schaffen es über den zaun zu
springen und ich versoffener penner so
drunk wie sonst üblich über den frauen
bringt der bremer rasch mir beide knie
auf und beide knie haben jetzt einfach
mal so einen fetten ratsch dingsbums die
nicht für immer da drin habe und die kuh
schon auf mich danach einfach noch an
und nur als war so abnormal täglich und
die kuh steht dann direkt neben mir und
wollte herausfinden auf mir drauf ist
und keine ahnung
das war dann echt so sachen da weiß
danach erstens vollem stinken zweitens
eine rose kapuze noch ganz andere sachen
die anderen hinter noch ins freibad
gefahren
also denkt ihr das ist ja der mann
betrunken ich kann euch auch ein foto
von meinen wunden gleichen firma
schicken
er warte mal wieviel punkte habt ihr am
2 ich habe 35
zwar war das damals anno ich war der
vierten klasse und wir alles meiner 10
11 und ich hab früher bei uns nicht so
gut auf bekommen und ich musste
richterin pisten und ich kann sie von
der schule habe ich nicht traut dazu
gehen oder kenne habe ich die tür nicht
aufgekommen
und dann kam die piste quasi schon raus
hier so ein bisschen in die hose gemacht
habe ich zu hause reflex einfach richtig
schön in so ein loch der man erkennt
dass du jetzt nicht noch zum zum
kellerfenster und habe ich einfach ein
gebiss vor der tür
also ich war damals shops und elefanten
macht also ich bin 16 geworden und dann
paar tage danach 16 geworden
ich bin 16 geworden aber es war nicht
mein geburtstag ist es passiert
ach so und das war ein wochenende und
dann links ja schon jahr probiere ich
ein bisschen was aus weiß bin ich 16 kam
mir wein und bier kaufen gleich kasala
machen
also habe ich die scheiße die ganze zeit
immer weiter gemischt getrunken
meine cousine war auch dabei
gern so viel gesoffen alter das war
nicht der fall also soviel meinem leben
und ich besoffen ja dann ist halt am
änderungen gekommen dass ich mit meiner
cousine umgelegt habe mein kopf ist
alter das ist wirklich eine lüge wenn
das keine lüge
du hast einer zigarette oder doch dann
glaube ich auch nicht dass du mit deiner
also eine dritte story wir waren wir
dann wieder saufen schiff bei einem
kurztreffen komischerweise bei einem
anderen kumpel und wir waren halt wieder
total voll bei solchen kurs treffen ist
einfach nur ab stürzt man hat wodka und
bacardi und alles bis zum gehtnichtmehr
aber halt nur billig sachen dann kann
dies jetzt nicht billig aber bin ich
wollte ganz was also mit man sich
eigentlich schon sehr gut abschließen
kann hier richtig abgeschossen also noch
nicht so heftig aber schon so richtig
richtig gut angetrunken und ein kumpel
von mir fast so hackl ich weiß dass die
leute die nicht mehr richtig geradeaus
fahrrad fahren können und was alles
jedenfalls fahrradfahrer kommt nicht
mehr geradeaus gehen er konnte nicht
mehr stehen mehr oder weniger ist
umgefallen naja jedenfalls wir bringen
ihn nach hause haben uns gedacht
erlauben wie ein streich und der musste
richtig packen dann gesagt bevor er dann
auf upload schuss oder etwas kaputt
macht sondern einfach zu den russischen
nachbarn gehen oder vor die tür scheißen
so ihre gedanken wie er ist stellt sich
vor die tür
was und wir stehen dahinter so zu ändern
dass natürlich gefilmt video auf dem
handy
ich jedenfalls das licht ging auf einmal
an und die haben nicht nur normales
licht weil wenn man manchmal für
bewegungs wichtige zu
das war kein normales nicht aber das war
locker mit zehn stadien fußball
beleuchtung wieder anging komplette
straße beleuchtet wir alle komplett hell
laufen alle weg er bleibt einfach davor
bleibt trotz seiner liga treu hat
einfach vor die tür
die wurst oder weißrussischer oper die
tür auf schreibt ihnen was auf russisch
irgendwas und nimmt seinen besen und
haut ihn einfach voll an den arsch und
er läuft weg und fällt in vorgärten und
läuft dann einfach weiter weg zu uns und
wir haben danach noch aufgebracht und
die mutter war dann auch stolz sind
sondern dürfte danach nicht mit uns nach
spanien auf links fahrstufen pfad blabla
vielleicht kann ich sag einfach das ist
eine lüge
ein punkt schon auf jeden fall wieder
voll fit stories und zwar kennt das ja
wenn man sich als kind ist auf schnee
freude so dass man immer richtig heiß
ein bisschen tauwetter und der schnee
war nicht wirklich da und ich war mit
meiner patentante und meiner mutter und
den sohn von meiner patentante aus dem
komischen der kanal und eiszapfen
gefunden oder science eiszapfen keiner
wollte mir das glauben
außer der sohn von meiner patentante
werden angenommen und an der schönen
geleckt und hätte sich mein gott ich
weiß es nicht
das ist so eine story die kann man
eigentlich glauben aber genau dann ist
man falsch in diesem spiel war dann ist
es eigentlich eine lüge
auch dieser kuscheln wieder ich weiß es
nicht ich sagt addio wie viel punkte
hast du jetzt vier du ich hab 134 vom 6
ich habe auch 6 das heißt ich muss
eigentlich das gleiche nehmen wie er
was hast du sagst war das ist auf jeden
fall war wichtig sagt hoffmann ist das
ärgerlich hat nicht mehr wahrgenommen
ich habe sieben punkte dieser diese
folge habe ich gewonnen
ich habe ein buch mitgenommen ich habe
aus liebe aber ich hab' 68
ihr hättet ihr hat 2005 wir hatten auch
noch in betracht gezogen dass der
verlierer der folge immerhin
bestrafungen machen muss also wenn ihr
da irgendwie noch was wisst gegen eine
erweiterung für diese serie dann könnt
ihr das auf 8 kommentare schreiben
erste folge kam jetzt bei beiden und die
zweite kommt dann bei mir nix manuell
feedback schreibt eure feedback wenn es
euch gefällt und die unbedingt mehr
wollen wir dass eventuell öfter
hochladen sollen oder sonst irgendwas
kann da und daumen hoch da lassen und
richtig spaß die geschichten wenn ihr
uns geschichten sendet an die
e-mail-adressen die wir gezeigt haben
oder vielleicht jetzt nochmal zeigen
weil sie das vergessen aber da oben hat
dann sendet malte und mir nicht die
gleiche geschichte mit dem ersten spiel
vorbei
also überlegt euch eine person denen ihr
die geschichte indem ihr die geschichte
also auch nicht ordentlich contractor
noch eure geschichte also müsst euch
eine person eine von uns eine person
aussuchen
genau deswegen haben wir eine
unterschiedliche e-mail- und ihr
schreibt einfach die geschichte dann war
oder lüge dahinter roger irgendwie sowas
so das wars mit der ersten folge von der
firma von der firma in der firma wie
gefällt euch eigentlich den firma
schreibt man kommt nach rom ist unser
warum sprechen wir mal was am
wichtigsten ist ich muss meinem team
nationalen moment nicht gut